it's great to be joined today by Terry
Cogan who's professor of law at the SJ
Quinney College of Law at the University
of Utah
you know this topic of bathrooms has
really come to the forefront of national
media mostly through discussions of
so-called transgender bathroom bills and
one of the arguments that we often hear
from those who are against laws that
allow individuals to use or rather those
who want individuals to be forced to use
the bathroom that matches their birth
genitals often argue that it's
completely natural obvious and has been
the way things are done forever that
bathrooms in public are segregated by
genitals that's not actually true is it
that's absolutely not true though you're
right that most people hold that
intuition that it makes perfect sense
that because there are two different
sexes and because people need privacy
that it's the natural way to separate
public restrooms in fact that is not how
the first laws in the United States came
about so talk to us for people who don't
know the backstory
when did sex segregated public restrooms
come about and people may have no idea
that this really does connect to the
industrial revolution in great part
absolutely so the first laws in the
United States
that required sex segregated restrooms
were adopted at the end of the 19th
century and they applied to factories
and other workplaces the first law was
in Massachusetts in 1887 New York
adopted a similar law the next year and
by 1920 over 40 states had adopted laws
requiring the factory restrooms be
separated by sex and I was interested
now several years ago in what led to
these laws being adopted and what I
discovered is that the
origin of these laws actually dates back
to the beginning of the 19th century and
the so called separate spheres ideology
and here's what that's all about until
the end of the 18th century the economy
of the United States what ran largely
out of the home men and women would not
only raise their families in the home
but through trades and crafts create
goods that would then be sold out of the
home as a result of the Industrial
Revolution manufacturing became
centralized in factories in the United
States and what started happening was
that men left the home to work in these
factories whereas women stayed in the
home to take care of their families and
there are roads as I suggested a vision
called the separate spheres ideology
which suggested that the proper sphere
for men was in the public realm in
factories as political leaders and the
proper sphere for women was in the home
watching the heart fires and raising
their kids this ideology was broadly
accepted culturally in the United States
beginning in the early 19th century the
problem was that shortly after the
beginning of the century women began
leaving the home to work in factories in
1822 when the textile factories for
example in Lowell Massachusetts were up
and running a large number of the
operatives in that fact in those
factories were women so there is this
cultural ideology that women should stay
at home and the reality of the evolving
nineteenth century is that women are
leaving the home in droves and you end
up with the following situation every
time a woman left the home to enter the
public realm it created
a kind of social cultural anxiety and in
response to that there were two
reactions by the mid 19th century the
first reaction was that states began
adopting protected labor legislation
that applied to women and children
legislation that limited the number of
hours that women could work legislation
that limited certain dangerous jobs only
to men a women were forbidden from those
jobs but in addition to this legislation
a very interesting architectural
response began happening in the United
States where there were separate public
separate spaces architectural spaces in
buildings created for women so for
example in public libraries early in the
nineteenth century women weren't allowed
in public libraries but once they were
allowed in such libraries beginning in
the 1840s you discover that separate
women's meeting rooms were created you
discovered that in hotels in photography
studios that would be separate in
department stores separate salons for
women and the idea was women are
inherently vulnerable when they enter
the public realm and therefore they need
a protected space when they enter the
public realm
so Terry if I may the it sounds like
what you're sort of saying is as we
often hear from social conservatives in
other areas what they want to present as
sort of the way things have been for as
far back as we can figure it out in
human society was actually something
sort of acutely established some time as
far back as the 19th century as you're
saying or some times as recently as the
1950s but at some point in the last
several hundred years the well be the
1850s
1850s I'm sorry I might have well no but
sometimes it seems like the
Conservatives want to go to the 1950s
specifically so that would be sort of
not with this particular issue but I was
sort of setting about right yeah that's
right that there is a sense that the
establishment of a custom as you
suggested earlier was simply natural the
way things should be and laws simply
reflect that natural state of things and
my research has shown that that's just
wrong so just to finish the story yeah
by the 1880s this notion of creating
exclusive spaces for women in public
began being applied to the factory and
the factory factories in the late 19th
century were dangerous places there is
no doubt about that
moreover given the rise of the Victorian
era men and women would work next to
each other in factories are on assembly
lines which caused great concern so the
solution to protect women and factories
was to create a kind of boom like Haven
in the public realm in the guise of a
separate public restroom there are also
laws that required separate dressing
rooms and there were laws that required
resting rooms for women all aimed at
protecting women in this dangerous
public realm what do we know if we go
further back and this goes beyond the
United States but maybe going back to
Europe in terms of bathroom spaces or
bathroom like spaces of course predating
modern plumbing or anything like it what
do we know about the organization of
these spaces with regard to gender okay
so realistically the possibility of a
multi-user
bathroom did not come about until the
technology of public works of sewer
systems allowed there to be indoor
plumbing
where the effluence was taken away from
buildings through sewers right and that
did not come about the first well-known
public bathrooms were at the Great
Exhibition in London in 18-49 in the
United States the technology did not
reach a stage public works were not
developed enough until the mid 1870s
that would even allow a multi-user
bathroom before then you have basically
separate single user privies outhouses
whatever
once in a while you would find that that
would be two of these privies next to
each other one labeled men one labeled
women but often that would be a single
Privy used by both sexes but what is
important is they were all single user
so the modern tension over bathrooms
only arises because of the possibility
of a multi-user bathroom and in the
United States that did not happen until
roughly the 1870s absolutely fascinating
and this is really really important to
keep in mind when we talk about and
evaluate arguments made around what
bathroom laws should be today it's
really important to have an
understanding of how things actually
were previously in human society we've
been speaking to Terry Cogan professor
of law at the SJ Quinney College of Law
at the University of Utah so great to
talk to you I really appreciate it David
it was good talking to you